welcome to the show everybody
i am
so glad that you guys are here thank you
for choosing to spend your time with us
um we refer to each other a lot around
here as a family
um and uh we thought we'd kick it up a
notch and and dedicate an entire hour to
my favorite word siblings
yeah
um
all of our guests are siblings today how
cool is that a audience full
of siblings
um and we even have two very special
co-hosts helping us which is a fun new
thing we're doing that's right we've got
co-hosts and uh guess what they're
identical twin sisters although
i think we all get that looking at you
guys um but here's a little behind the
scenes of what it takes to be a co-host
watch this please
hi i'm alicia crowe and i'm alice crow
and we're identical twins and lawyers
we're partnering to
revive our mother's hot sauce business
this has impacted our family in such an
incredible way coming together around
this was so special
we are so
super excited to come on the show and
meet drew oh we are fans of drew
barrymore i love what she's doing with
her show
and positive and it's funny
we love her humor she's helping to make
the world a better place
see you soon drew
[Music]
hi everyone we just arrived at the
studios we're so excited to be here we
are co-hosting the drew barrymore show
let's go inside
hi ladies
i have your co-host binders right here
thank you all right let's head on down
we're here we're in front of the studio
we're ready to co-host with drew let's
go inside we're so excited
please say hello to alice and alicia
[Applause]
i'm so honored that you came to hang out
today oh thank you thank you so much for
having us um well please um if i've
missed anything jump in i'll turn the
questions over to you guys and we'll do
this together
sounds good excellent
it is time for a pick from the little
yellow book which is my personal guide
to all things i can't wait to share with
you and today it's some homespun hot
sauce that's been making mouths tingle
since 1910
it's emmeline's all-natural hot sauce
and alicia and alice
this is your grandmother's beautiful
recipe 1910.
1910 that's her wedding picture in 1910.
look at that on the label that's
beautiful oh my gosh and i have to say
um i was lucky enough to pour it all
over my food because i was like can i
just get by the way i'm salivating
talking about all my plans or losing
their minds um i wanted to taste it
before we talked about it so that i
could discuss it it's so wonderful
delicate spicy i couldn't have loved it
more in fact i'm going in right now i
have a question for you on a scale of
one to burn my tongue off how hot is it
it's not really hot
it's flavorful
with just enough kick to spark your joy
i'd like my joy
i would love to have my joy spark thank
you so much
i i really think that it's a very unique
thought like i have not tasted a sauce
like that and i'm not saying that to be
polite i think it's really stands apart
from
all the noise out there thank you you
know after we lost our mom during the
pandemic we were like you know what
let's see if we could get her hot sauce
you know going let's honor her memory by
carrying forward one of her dreams you
know revive something that she started
let me tell you something that's
beautiful and this sauce is so good we
could put it on the news desk and i'd
eat it okay
thank you for that and thank you for
this thank you for bringing us
emmeline's beautiful sauce and carrying
on the tradition in honor of your mother
thank you thank you for having me to the
generation and the legacy of your family
and thank you for being here and
representing siblings alice and alicia
it's been such a privilege to co-host
with you
and um this has just been an absolute
pleasure and um
we appreciate you choosing to spend your
time with us we make this show for you
so please take it with you
and we'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
you